[Music]
you
you
you
[Music]
because I just want to propose a toast
to Friendship and yeah just having great
times together so glad you came I hope
you're all having fun
you
are you having fun yeah yeah that's
really nice my so happy it's so nice to
see you yeah it's really lovely it's
really really fun it's been really fun
it's amazing
[Music]
but I'm I'm pleased I didn't go to
university I got I mean I know you've
met a lot of people and that your
friends for life but I don't think that
like paying nine thousand a year to make
friends is really the best use of my
money you know especially if I'm gonna
have to pay that back
I may have our friend into the
contemporary movement practice I learned
to walk when I was little I don't need
to live I just learned that myself
you follow if you get help he doesn't I
don't need to tutor to tell me you know
this is how movement looks in 20th
century just say bus stop it was the
village councillor and that's it you
know they're all in the bed of breakfast
and that's where it begins you know it's
this orgy situation and I think first of
all it's abuse of power but why people
need to commit to group sex
I just I find it so weird
and I'm gonna creep here discussing like
I just I do not want to be in harness
doing that kind of thing I'm just I'm
not interested I think it's disgusting I
I just I don't understand why somebody
needs to have multiple partners cause
you're so strong so good and talented
and it is very unique I think actually
you know what would happen if you just
stripped it all back and took away all
the bells and whistles the effects and
just kind of just went justyou just the
guitar just helped that's rude
to sit there and just that's quite
arrogant just to tell me what you think
I should do with what I'm doing like
what what do you even know about music
that do you know in it that you just
press buttons and stuff don't you just
press play and of course you don't
actually create any music so for you to
tell me what to do with mines just
really it comes across really full of
yourself
you
that you don't know what you're talking
about I know what I'm doing with my
music and if it doesn't appeal to you
I'm sorry but you probably don't kind of
know that genre that I'm going for or
the feeling that maybe I'm not going for
a genre what genre would you say my work
was you don't know because you don't
know music
don't tell me how to do my craft in
front of my friends and how I'm doing
but you get it you absolutely get it
earlier he doesn't get it
[Music]
I'm so much happier being single like I
couldn't you know the movies here even
good on your own like I didn't know that
I thought it was a couple thing but even
that's even that's good now you know
I've got more space in the apartment
at the School of Life we believe in
developing emotional intelligence to
that end we've also created a whole
range of products to support that growth
find out more at the link on the screen
now
you